l'interdiction d'entrée est placardée
sur la porte au petit matin l'accès au
bâtiment est toujours limité l'alerté a
été donnée hier soir par une résidente
constatant une fissure sur l'un des murs
de son appartement
venu récupérer quelques affaires cette
voisine raconte la suite à 10 heures
j'ai entendu des craquements mais bon je
me suis dit c'est la voisine du dessus
sa fille fait un petit peu bruyant mais
bon sans plus et puis bah ma fille sera
10 heures la chienne et puis me dit
moment il ya les gendarmes les pompiers
et puis il faut évacuer
donc on n'en savait pas plus on a tous
été dehors et puis on nous a dit que
c'était un mur qui s'effondrait
soi-disant par principe de précaution
l'immeuble du bailleur social
départemental domanys comprenant 20
logements sur cinq niveaux a été
complètement évacué
d'abord accueillis au centre social tout
proche les 33 résidents ont dû être
relogés le temps du passage d'un expert
je suis chez des amis et normalement
devrait rentrer chez nous aujourd'hui on
vous a dit quoi là pour l'instant on
nous a dit que c'était une fissure dans
le mur du logement en dessous de chez
nous et une grande fissure mais sans
gravité
c'est une fissure entre un mur et une
cloison de chambre qui ne pose pas de
problème sur le bâti par contre
effectivement là des réparations à faire
sur sur ce mur on vient d'avoir le
retour de cet expert qui nous dit il n'y
a pas de danger sur la structure les
habitants ont commencé à regagner leur
domicile en fin de journée sauf les
résidents de l'appartement en question
ils seront relogés le temps des travaux
de réhabilitation de cette cloison
fissurer